so a lot of the concepts that you learn
about in multivariable calculus are
really all about taking ideas that you
originally might have learned in linear
algebra and then transferring those to
apply to non-linear problems so for
example i'm going to give you a function
some kind of function that takes in a 2d
vector xy
and it's also going to spit out a 2d
vector
and the specific one i have in mind this
is
just kind of arbitrary is x plus sine of
y
and then because i'm a sucker for
symmetry i'm going to make it y
plus sine of x of course you know this
could be any arbitrary function you
don't need that kind of symmetry so in
the last video i gave a little refresher
on how to think about linear
transformations and ideas from linear
algebra and how you encode a linear
transformation using a matrix and kind
of visualize it i use this grid
and here i want to show what this
function looks like as a transformation
of space as in i'm going to tell the
computer take every single point on this
blue grid here and if that point is x y
i want you to move it over to the point
x plus sine of y y plus sine of x
and here's what that looks like
all right so things get really wavy
really curly this is not at all a linear
transformation right all of the lines
don't remain lines they're no longer
nice grid lines that are parallel and
evenly spaced uh in some sense there is
much much more information that goes
into non-linear functions then into
linear functions
and because this is rather complicated i
think it might be
easier to see what's going on if we just
focus on a single individual point so
let me look at a point like
let's say
pi
and 0.
so if that's what i'm plugging in x is
pi halves so at the top here x
stays the same it's pi halves and then
sine of y would be sine of 0. so that x
component is going to completely stay
the same
and then for the bottom
y well y is also 0
plus sine of x sine of pi halves is 1.
i'm just i'll go ahead and write sine of
pi halves
sine of
pi
halves
but you can think of that as just being
1.
so what that means on the transformation
over here is if we look at the point
that's at pi halves 0 and pi halves is a
little above 1.5 so that's going to be
around here
we expect it to move to the point pi
halves one so it should just move
vertically by one unit and if you just
focus on that one point during the
transformation
notice that's exactly what happens it
just moves vertically one point
and of course things are quite
complicated because every point is doing
that right the computer's taking in
every point and moving it to where it
should go
so after having given the refresher on
thinking about linear transformations
and encoding them with matrices last
time something like this might feel
completely intractable
you certainly have to store much more
information than just four numbers to
record where everything goes
but this function has a nice property a
property that we deal with all the time
in multivariable calculus it's what we'd
call locally linear
locally
linear
and what that means is if i was to take
our initial setup and then zoom in on a
given point so i'm going to zoom in
around this point on the left here and
this box kind of in the upper right just
shows the zoomed in version of that and
first of all i'm going to add some more
grid lines so they're really very close
grid lines right we can see from the
zoomed out picture but this just makes
it so that when we're zoomed in we can
see a little bit more of what's going on
and now when i play the animation i'm
going to have this yellow box that's
doing the zooming to follow the point at
its center right so this box will be
moving and we're always just going to
look at what it zoomed in on okay so
it's going to be following what's going
on around that point during the
transformation
and we can see inside this zoomed
version it's still not linear right the
lines get a little bit curved but this
looks a lot more like a linear function
it looks a lot more like the grid lines
that started off horizontal and vertical
are remaining parallel and evenly spaced
and in fact let's say i zoom in even
further to an even smaller yellow box
here and again i'm going to add in some
more grid lines right around it so
they're very very densely packed and
this is this is purely an artifact of
visualizing things right i could choose
to put points or lines or anything
wherever i want and i just think showing
the grid lines and only the grid lines
and where they move gives sort of a feel
for what the function is doing so this
time when i play it and that zooming in
box kind of tracks the point that we're
looking at
as it goes
the neighborhood around it all of the
points around it really really do look
like a linear function
and the more you zoom in the more it
looks precisely like a certain linear
function
oh i guess i should have written an r
over here
locally linear so this raises the
question if we're looking around some
specific point which i'll call x naught
and y naught
this should correspond in some way to
the linear transformation that it looks
like around it there should be some kind
of matrix some two by two matrix that
represents the linear transformation
that this function this much more
complicated function looks like around
that point
so this idea of zooming in is what we
mean by local and in the next video i'm
going to show you what this matrix looks
like in terms of partial derivatives for
our original function see you then